WILL COME TO ORDER IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN CAPITAL ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH NONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
DISSIPATING REMOTELY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH ME OUR
SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY GLAZER
MCGUIRE A TROUBLED AND PAN. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
REMOVED A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESS THE SLIDE
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WEEK WANT TO RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING ON THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE JUST INTO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
SO AGAIN PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
AND PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE A
LEVEL BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
EIGHT BILLS ARE ON CONSENT THE
BILLS ON CONSENT OUR- ITEM
THREE. AB THREE OH SIX ITEM FOR
AB THREE THREE SEVEN. ITEM FIVE
AB FIVE FORTY THREE. ITEM SIX
SB SIX FORTY THREE ITEM SEVEN
AB FIVE EIGHT FIFTY SIX. ITEM
EIGHT AB TEN THIRTY NINE. EIGHT
ITEM NINE AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. AND ITEM TEN ACR FIFTY
THREE. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S
POLITICOS TABLETS A QUORUM.
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA HERE
THEY WERE HERE UNTIL ABODE.
TROUBLED CORTESE IT HAS A HAIR
TALLY GLAZER YOUR GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HERE PAN AM
HERE. A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED MEMBERS LET'S TAKE
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THIS
TIME DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE MENEM'S. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA HI OF
TROUBLE BUG PATROL BOGOTA A
COURTESY CORTEZ THE ICE DALY
GLAZER. HI GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
CHOIR I PAN HI CAN I. WE WILL
THE ON CALL ABSENT LET'S HEAR
NOW FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHILD AND HE'S GOING TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY NINE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
AB THIRTY NINE WOULD CODIFY AND
RECOGNIZED THE CALIFORNIA CHINA
CLIMATE INSTITUTE. TO
ACCELERATE CLIMATE ACTION
THROUGH COOPERATIVE. EFFORTS IN
EXCHANGES BETWEEN TWO OF THE
WORLD'S. LARGEST ECONOMIC
POWERS AND MAJOR IN MATTERS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES. CALIFORNIA
AND CHINA. THERE ARE MANY
SERIOUS THREATS WE FACE THAT
ARE CONSTRAINED BY NATIONAL
BORDERS. AND AFFECT EVERYONE
AROUND THE WORLD THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE THAT
CLEAR. THE CLIMATE CHANGE
CRISIS IS NO DIFFERENT. BECAUSE
OF CALIFORNIA'S PROXIMITY TO
CHINA IT BENEFITS OUR STATE
GREATLY IF CHINA IS ABLE TO
REDUCE ITS T. X. T. EMISSIONS.
CHINA CURRENTLY IN ITS 28% OF
THE WORLD'S CARBON DIOXIDE
EMISSIONS. MEANWHILE WE HAVE
OUR OWN AIR POLLUTION
CHALLENGES IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THE LOS ANGELES
AREA IS THE SMOGGIEST METRO
AREA IN THE COUNTRY. FOR THE
TWENTY FIRST TIME IN THE LAST
TWENTY TWO YEARS. IN FACT NINE
OF THE TEN SMOGGIEST COUNTIES
IN THE COUNTRY ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH SAMPOERNA DINO
RIVERSIDE AND LOS ANGELES.
COUNTIES BEING THE FIRST SECOND
AND THIRD WORST IN THE NATION.
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND REDUCE EMISSIONS WE MUST
HAVE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS AROUND
THE WORLD. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN FORMER CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR
HELPED LAUNCH THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA CLIMATE INSTITUTE. TO
PROMOTE CLIMATE ACTION THROUGH
JOINT RESEARCH TRAINING AND
DIALOGUE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
CHINA. THE INSTITUTE IS
PARTNERING WITH LEADING
ACADEMIC AND GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES IN CHINA. AND
PROVIDING A PLATFORM TO BUILD
THESE VIRTUALLY NEEDED
PARTNERSHIPS. THE INSTITUTE
ADVANCES JOINT POLICY RESEARCH
ON MAJOR CLIMATE ISSUES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED. TO
CARBON LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION ZERO EMISSION V.
HOLES ALL CARBON PRICE CLIMATE
ADEPT AND RESILIENCE
SUSTAINABLE LAND USE AND
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE AND
LONG TERM CLIMATE GOAL SETTING
AND POLICY ENFORCEMENT. PASSING
AB THIRTY NINE AND FORMALIZING
THE INSTITUTE IN TATE LAW THE
LEGISLATURE CONSENTED STRONG
MESSAGE THAT CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WAY TO
REVERSE CLIMATE CHANGE BY
ADVANCING JOIN CLIMATE RESEARCH
THROUGH KERR COLLABORATION
THROUGH THE INSTITUTE. I HAVE
OF FORMER GOT CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR THE HONORABLE EDMUND
G. BROWN JUNIOR AND NIKITA
KHARADI WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A RIVAL
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL
FIRST GO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE TWO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE WE WILL
NOW GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND
SEE IF WE HAVE BEEN SEEING NO
ONE WILL NOW GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES FOR THE LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOVERNOR BROWN ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I SURE. MADAM
CHAIR PLEASE LISTEN GOOD TO
SPEAK WITH YOU AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS. OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS SIMPLE BILL. GATES FOR
EXPLORING BUT IT'S AUTHORS TO
CYNICALLY I WOULD JUST SAY THIS
THAT- SPEAKING FROM WHERE I AM
AT THIS VERY MOMENT. WE'RE
EXPERIENCING THE DRIEST
WEATHER- IN THE KNOWLEDGE OF
ANYBODY IN THIS AREA OF WEST
COLUSA COUNTY THE CREATURE
DRYING UP. THE COWS HAVE BEEN
REMOVED TO A BETTER CLIMATES IN
THE NORTH- WE WERE LOOKING AT-
REAL FIRE DANGER. AND NOT USING
COLUSA BUT ALL OVER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IT TURNS OUT THAT
IT CALIFORNIA AND THE WESTERN
PART OF THE UNITED STATES. IN
NORTHERN CHINA AND THE
MEDITERRANEAN OUR PARTICULAR
HOT SPOT. IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS WE'RE GONNA BE
EXPERIENCING- DRY SOILS LOW
HUMIDITY AND REAL FIRE DANGER
IF NOT BY A REALITY SO THIS
BILL- KIND OF FLIES IN. PUTS
THE LEGISLATIVE STAMP OF
APPROVAL ON OUR INTELLECTUAL
AND ACADEMIC EFFORT TOWARD
CHRISTIAN LAW UNIVERSITY WITH
MINISTRY SHIA THE CHINESE
AMBASSADOR. TO THE PARIS
CONFERENCE TO WORK SO CLOSELY
WITH JOHN KERRY AND PRESIDENT
OBAMA. THIS IS A PROFOUNDLY
SERIOUS ISSUE THAT PLENTY OF
OTHER. THINGS IN THE ITEMS THAT
YOU WORRY ABOUT AND THINK ABOUT
WITH REGARD TO CHINA AND OTHER
THINGS GOING ON IN THE WORLD
BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT. WE HAVE A
PROBLEM- WITH CLIMATE CHANGE WE
MUST REDUCE AND ELIMINATE A
CARBON EMISSIONS AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO ADAPT.
AND INTRODUCE- GREAT RESILIENCY
INTO OUR FORESTS ARE OUR CITIES
OUR WATERS ARE COASTAL AREAS.
IT IS QUITE A CHALLENGE AND IT
CAN'T BE DONE. WITHOUT
COOPERATION WITH CHINA CHINA IS
EMITTING A 28% UNITED STATES IS
EMITTING A. 13% HISTORICALLY WE
THE EMITTED MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE AND PUT MORE SHE TWO IN
THE ATMOSPHERE STILL. SO WE A
JOINT DRAW. IT'S WHAT I CALL.
REAL ISSUE COMMON FOLDER BILL.
COMMON TAKES A OMMON SOLUTION
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALL OF WITH
WORLD BUT THIS ONE GOT A ON
WHATEVER ELSE WE'RE ALL IN THE
IN SO IT STANDS ITSELF.
DISTANCE IN A VERY AND-
RELATION. CAL OUR FUTURE HE IS
EXISTENTIAL IT REQUIRES ACTION
AND WHILE THIS IS NO PANACEA IT
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP. IN
LISTING- THE BEST THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
BEST OF THE CHINESE
UNIVERSITIES AT GETTING AT THIS
PROBLEM IN A NON POLITICAL
THEORY IS SCIENTIFIC WAY I.
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
GOVERNOR WE YOU'RE- WE ARE
GOING TO OUR NAY. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO OUR WITNESS SINCE THE-
MS MCGEE CORDED. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE MORNING TECH-
BROWN THIS IS NIKI MCCARTY BUT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. I DON'T EASY PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB THIRTY NINE TODAY
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE REGIONS OF
THE UC TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE THE SERVER THE THINK
TANK WITH THE PURPOSE OF
ADVANCING CLIMATE POLICY. AND
ONE OF THE FIRST INTERNATIONAL
NONPROFIT TO LAUNCH A CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAM IN CHINA AND IF
YOU'VE BEEN SUPPORTING CHINA'S
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT BY
PROVIDING TECHNICAL AND LEGAL
EXPERTISE FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS. THE MID NINETEEN
NINETIES WE'VE BEEN
COLLABORATING WITH A WIDE RANGE
OF CHINESE AND INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS TO FACILITATE
EXCHANGES AND LEARNING DEVELOP
INNOVATIVE POLICY TOOLS TRAIN
TRAINEE LEGAL PROFESSIONALS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCACY AND
INTRODUCE AND DEMONSTRATE BEST
PRACTICES AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY
TRANSITIONING TO CLEAN ENERGY
POLLUTION CONTROL WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION AND LOW CARBON
URBANIZATION. FOR EXAMPLE THE
WORKED AT CHINESE PORTS TO
BEGIN TO REDUCE EMISSIONS USING
MANY OF THE LESSONS LEARNED AT
THE COURT OF LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH MUCH LIKE ENERGY
COULD WORK IN CHINA THE
CALIFORNIA TRYING TO CLIMATE
INSTITUTES MISSION OF
PREDICATED. ON THE RECOGNITION
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES
ARE NOT CONFINED BY GEOGRAPHIC
BORDERS WE SEE GREAT VALUE IN
THE INSTITUTE FOCUSED ON JOINT
RESEARCH TRAINING DIALOGUE
COLLABORATION AND EXPLORATION
OF URGENTLY NEEDED CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS AT ALL LEVELS. FOR
THESE REASONS PRINT THE PART OF
AB THIRTY NINE TODAY I THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH- OPERATOR CAN
YOUR MOTTO CAN YOU. FOR ANYBODY
IN ON THE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SO. OF AB THIRTY
NOW. YES MADAM CHAIR AND
ACTUALLY READY HAVE SOME CUTE
UP IN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IN EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
IN THE PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE SO AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH
WIND TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LYING TO YOU ARE YOU SAID LINE
DANCE I'M IN OPPOSITION- I'M
SORRY WE'RE DOING SUPPORT RIGHT
NOW SO PLEASE RE QUEUE AT THAT
TIME. ALL RIGHT AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT CHAU PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR A. B.
THIRTY NINE AND WE WERE LINE
TWENTY SIX. TWENTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. WE CAN HEAR YOU TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON
AND- WIND TWENTY SEVEN. I'M
SORRY I'M IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
HOLD ONE FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT.
WE WILL GET TO OPPOSITION
ASCETIC AND. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY
IS KILLING UP THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR OKAY MEMBERS WILL NOW
MOVE TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION HERE AND
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE BACK TO YOU
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE.
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY NINE PLEASE. I WAS
DEBATING WE'RE DONE. I HAVE GOT.
OUR LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN.
HI THIS IS HEATHER KELLER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. THIRTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME AND LINE
TWENTY SIX YOUR YOUR OPEN.
BLIND TWENTY SIX HOW DID YOU-
I'M GOING TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A MOMENT SINCE YOU DID NOT
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO READ A STATEMENT
PLEASE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
SPELL YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
PLEASE PROCEED. FIFTEEN MONTHS
AGO A GROUP OF CHINESE
SCIENTISTS WORKING ON THE
GROUND AT THE SCENE OF THE
OUTBREAK OF A BRAND NEW VIRUS
CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT THE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS. PROBABLY
ESCAPED FROM A GOVERNMENT LAB
IN WUHAN. HE SAID SO IN A
RESPONSIBLE TERMS AND POSTED IT
ON THE INTERNET THE MODERN
VERSION. ARCHERY IS ABOUT CHOI
AND I HAVE A TO. YOU CAN ON THE
M. THIS IS YOUR COMMENTS ARE
NOT RELATED TO THE BILL. OKAY
MOVING ON WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK THAT WAS DISAPPOINTING-
YEAH THIS IS MIKE AND- I'M IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I'M
ALSO IN OPPOSITION DO YOU GUYS
CUTTING OFF THE PEOPLE BECAUSE-
THEY ARE SAYING MISTER MODERATE
RATE OVER THE NEXT CALLER HOW
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO FEEL. K. UP.
WE WILL LINE TWENTY- SKEWS ME
LYING TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
YES I AM LIBERTY WAR AND I IN
THE STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY NINE AND ALSO CANCELING
AMENDMENT ONE THANK YOU. ALLEN
AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DOT COM COSTA COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB THIRTY NINE
AND YOUR SILENCE IN THE PEOPLE
WHO WHICH. AND AS A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTY NINE.
ONE MOMENT THAT I'M SURE WE DO
HAVE A PARTICIPANT WITH AN
OPERATOR. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIX FIVE THREE THREE FROM
ROSEVILLE- I OPPOSE THIS- WE'RE
NOT- MY CHANNING DR SHOULD
OPERATE NOW NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ADRIAN HAD- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION A. B. THREE NINE AND
ALTHOUGH THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IS OVER YOU NEED TO OPEN A
HOSPITAL I BELIEVE PEOPLE. IT
WAS I. MOVING ALONG WILL
BORDERLINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MARK MEADOWS HERE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M SURE THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU
CHAIR IS SAID GOVERNOR BROWN
STILL ON THE LINE PER QUESTION
DO WE KNOW IF GOVERNOR I'M NOT-
OKAY VERY GOOD PLEASE PROCEED
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU A
GOVERNOR I UNDERSTAND YOUR
PROFESSOR- NOW DO YOU PREFER
BEING ADDRESSED AS PROFESSOR
BROWN OR GOVERNOR BROWN. THAT
QUESTION IS IT SELF I LIKE
BEING GOVERNOR ALTHOUGH I'M
GLAD NOT TO BE THERE NOW OKAY
THANK YOU GOVERNOR AYE WE- I
APPRECIATE YOUR ABILITY I'M NOT
BEING FOR FREIGHT IS A
PROFESSOR THEY ONLY GIVE ME
PSYCHIC INCOME. THAT IS A
WONDERFUL TOUCH DOWN- OF
MEMORIES THANK YOU GOVERNOR AND
THANK YOU FOR LENDING YOUR
POWERFUL VOICE TO THIS ISSUE OF
CLIMATE- YOU BEEN RELENTLESS
AND- AND CLEAR ABOUT THE THREAT
IT FACES AND I'M I'M- HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I. I
DID WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION
THAT- HAS SOME PEOPLE CONCERNED
AND ALLOW YOU TO ADDRESS IT AS
IT RELATES TO THIS BILL- THAT
THAT CONCERN REVOLVES AROUND
HUMAN RIGHTS- IN PARTICULAR OF
RECENT NOTE THAT. THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE HOW THE UIGHURS ARE
BEING TREATED IN IN THE COUNTRY
COULD YOU. SPEAK TO THAT IF YOU
WISH. YEAH VERY MUCH SO I KNEW
THIS IS OF DEEP CONCERN. THAT
IS OF CONCERN TO ME IN TO.
ANYBODY WHO REALLY KNOWS WHAT'S
GOING ON- THERE'S LOTS OF
THINGS GOING ON IN CHINA. AS
THAT I DON'T LIKE. IT ENDED TOO
OF ALL THE COLUSA. HIM JUST
WHICH WE DON'T LIKE EITHER. BUT
THE FACT IS A CLIMATE. IS A
PLANETARY CHALLENGES IN
EXPONENTIAL CHALLENGE. DURING
THE COLD WAR WITH RUSSIA WHEN
WE GET SEVERE- DISAGREEMENT. IN
THE FEAR OF INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNISM- TAKING OVER THE
WORLD- AMERICANS STILL ENTERED
INTO. A NUCLEAR AGREEMENT TO
MAKE THE WORLD SAFE FROM A%
NUCLEAR ACCIDENT OR NUCLEAR WAR
WE HAVE THE ANY SIMILAR. TO IT
IN CLIMATE. CLIMATE IS A THREAT
TO PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD.
HEY WE CAN'T SOLVE IT WE CAN'T
EVEN GET CLOSE TO SOLVING IT
WITHOUT CHINESE EFFORT REAL
CHINESE EFFORTS. IN REDUCING
ELIMINATING THE COAL- REDUCING
THE OIL IN THEIR GAS JUST LIKE
WE HAVE TO DO THE SAME THING.
SO WE'RE FACING HERE A
PLANETARY CORRECT. AND WE HAVE
TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT IT DEAL
WITH IT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE-
ATTEMPTING. AT THE- CALIFORNIA
CHINA CLIMATE INSTITUTE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO WE CAN SOLVE. ALL
THE PROBLEMS THE WORLD BUT WE
CAN ADVANCE SERIOUS.
INTELLECTUAL INQUIRY IN HOW WE
DEAL. WITH CARBON EMISSIONS HOW
WE ADAPT TO THE RISING
TEMPERATURES RISING SEA LEVEL
AND THE DISRUPTIVE- WHETHER
EVENTUALLY WERE ALL IN JANUARY.
SO IT'S A POSITIVE AND- SOME
PEOPLE MAY FIND IT DIFFICULT.
BUT YOU CAN OPPOSE PEOPLE. CALL
PREFER. AND YET ON A CALM
THREAT AND A COMMON GOAL. WHICH
CLIMATE CHANGE. PRESENTS DOUBLE
CHINA AMERICA WE CAN FIND.
LIMON A GO. GOING FORWARD AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS. WE
TO CAN- WORKING ALL AT A JOINT
PROBLEM WE JOINT STRATEGY SO
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING IT
DOESN'T MINIMIZE ANY EFFORT TO-
PROTECT HUMAN RIGHTS IN CHINA
OR ANYWHERE ELSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- PROFESSOR I MEAN
HE'S BEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
PRECIADO- YOUR INSIGHT AND THAT
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS ISSUE
HERE AND ACROSS THE- STREET
CAMPAIGN CONTROL NO I MEAN
SENATOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS THANK YOU
GOVERNOR BROWN WE APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS GREAT I MISS
ALL OF YOU. COME BY SOMETIME
SELDES GREAT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ARE COMMON IN
THE COMMITTEE. YES SENATOR
MCGUIRE YOU SO MUCH VERY GOOD
FROM CHAIR INTO AND BRIGITTE
THE QUESTION THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM RENEE DANCE AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO ALSO ASK- SOONER
CHAT IS A MEMBER CHAO SO LOOK.
I THINK THAT THE CONCERN IS
THAT THAT IS PROBABLY A 100%
AGREEMENT AT THESE TWO NATIONS
NEED TO WORK CLOSER TOGETHER ON
ALL ISSUES OF CLIMATE- NOW
THOUGH- BUT WE SEE A FOCUS
EVENT COMPLETE EXTERMINATION OF
A CULTURE WITHIN THE COUNTRY
COUNTRY. OF CHINA WITH UIGHUR
MUSLIMS. IT IS OF GREAT CONCERN
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT I KNOW
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOW IS
FOCUSING IN ON ONE OF YOUR TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO DISCUSS
HAT BECAUSE- CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ONE OF THE GREATEST THREATS OF
OUR TIME IN IF YOU'RE WE ARE
MUSLIM IN THAT COUNTRY. CHINA
IS THE GREATEST THREAT TO YOUR
FAMILY AT THIS TIME SO IF YOU
DON'T MIND COMING ON THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE ARE
GROWING CONCERNS PLEASE
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR AND I WISH I
COULD REPEAT WHAT THE GOVERNOR.
SAID EARLIER BUT ESSENTIALLY I
AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR I IN
THE SENSE THAT- YOU KNOW-
EASIER CHINA MAY HELP POLICIES
THAT WE DO NOT ALL AGREE WITH
AND OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THIS IS
HUMAN RIGHTS IS ONE OF THOSE-
YEAH. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
SENTIMENT AND SAID EXPRESSED BY
YOURSELF AND ALSO THE CALLERS.
YEAH BUT- I THINK WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO OUR SEPARATE ISSUES
LIKE THE GOVERNOR SAID AND
IDENTIFY WHO WANTS THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THEM ON AND CLIMATE
CHANGE DEFINITELY IS ONE OF
THOSE. GUYS AS I STATED
EARLIER- AND THE GOVERNOR-
CHINA CURRENTLY EMITS LIKE 20%
OF THE WORLD'S CARBON DIOXIDE
THAT'S KIND OF STUFF THAT WE
KIND OF SECONDARY SINGLE DAY.
NOW THAT TRANSLATES TO TEN OP
BILLION METRIC TONS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE SUIT YOU KNOW AND GIVEN
THE PROXIMITY THAT WE ARE WITH
CHINA. TO IT BENEFITS GREATLY
FOR YOU KNOW FOR US TO WORK
WITH DOWN. AND YOU KNOW THE GET
THEIR NUMBERS THAT TO. IS
MANAGER. SO 2% THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT REALLY NOTHING TO SNEEZE
AT. SO YOU KNOW THIS ONE AREA
THAT WE CAN WORK IN FACT THAT'S
WHAT THE CONFEDERATE IS. TO BY
THE GOVERNOR AN EXISTENTIAL.
THREAT TO THE CLIMATE DOT AND
YOU KNOW THE SPECIFICS THAT YOU
KNOW THE NUMBERS I CITED EARLY
ALSO INDICATE THAT AS WELL. SO
I DO UNDERSTAND THE SENTIMENT.
EXPRESSED SIDE SO- BUT I THINK
THIS IS ONE AREA THAT WE CAN
WORK ON STAR WITH CHINA. THE
SIMPSONS. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU AND I HAVE TO MAY ALSO
SHARE THE CONCERNS OF MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS
RECORDS- WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
UIGHURS WE CAN ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE DEMOCRACY ACTIVISTS IN HONG
KONG WHAT'S HAPPENING IN HONG
KONG AS WELL- THE BILLING. OF
TAIWAN AS WELL. FOR ANY FROM
ENTERING THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION- SO THESE ARE
CERTAINLY SIGNIFICANT SERMONS-
HOWEVER I GUESS MY QUESTION TO
YOU HERE IS THAT- THE INSTITUTE
ITSELF- WHICH- IS- WHICH- YOU
SEE YOU BUSINESS PARTNERSHIPS.
IS THAT. IT THEY JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S NOT FUNDED BY THE STATE.
ITSELF RIGHT IT'S IT WOULD BE
UC COLLABORATING. WITH THE
UNIVERSITY AND- IN CHINA IT
DOLLARS IT WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
ARE CURRENTLY THE ICE OUT IT'S
GOT TO THE GOVERNMENT. I'LL BE
GLAD TO COMMENT LIBRARIES THE
MONEY WE'VE- THIS ISSUE.
PRIVATE MONEY COMING FROM
NONPROFIT HEWLETT. HAS
CONTRIBUTED IT'S ABOUT A TWO
MILLION DOLLAR OPERATION-
HEWITT- IS THE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR AND WE HAVE WE HAVE
OTHERS BLOOMBERG- IN
DISCIPLINES NO MONEY. FROM A
CHINESE ENTITIES. OKAY FOR THIS
TO GO. OKAY TEN AND THIS IS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN YOU SEE
AND- THE- THREE MORE UNIVERSITY
IN BEIJING THE BIGGEST. MOST
IMPORTANT UNIVERSITY IN CHINA
ONE OF MOST UNIVERSITIES IN THE
WORLD ALL RIGHT SO THE TOTAL
BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER I
DO SAY SO MYSELF MY PHILOSOPHY
IS WHAT I CALL POLITICALLY
REALISM THERE ARE CERTAIN-
THREATS THE VIRUS- THE DANGER
OF NUCLEAR WAR OR MISTAKE OR
MISCALCULATION- CYBER ASSAULTS-
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
MILITARIZATION SPACE THAT
AFFECTS EVERYBODY ON PLANET
EARTH AND WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TO CHIP AWAY AT EACH OF THOSE
PROBLEMS FOR THE BILL IN
GOLFERS THERE HAVE BEEN
SERIOUS- SCHOLARS WHO WERE
SAYING THAT THE POTENTIALITY OF
HUMAN EXTINCTION IS NO REAL- TO
BE ORDERED FROM OXFORD
ESTIMATES WE HAVE A ONE IN SIX
CHANCE. IN THIS CENTURY OF THE
UNRECOVERABLE COLLAPSE THE
CIVILIZATION ONE OF THE KEY
CONTRIBUTORS TO THIS THREAT IS
CLIMATE CHANGE THE GOVERNMENTS
IN CHINA WILL COME AND GO WE'VE
BEEN ENEMIES WE'VE BEEN FRIENDS
THE SAME IS TRUE OF OTHER
COUNTRIES GERMANY AND JAPAN
WE'VE GOT TO WORK ON THIS LONG
TERM THREAT THE OVER HERE. LONG
AFTER. THE CURRENT CROP OF
LEADERS IN- GOING FORGOT. A
WELL I WAS BABY HEALTH APP
CREATE THAT FOR FROM THE
GOVERNOR I GUESS WAS A SAY IS
THAT- FROM I UNDERSTAND THIS
REALLY IN ANY WAY A CROSS
UNIVERSE. CALL WITH BETWEEN YOU
SEE AND THE UNIVERSITY COULD
YOU KNOW CLEARLY- YUP CHINA IS
I THINK RIGHT NOW THE SECOND
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
PERHAPS THERE'S EVEN SOME
TALKING TO BECOME THE LARGEST
ECONOMY- IT'S COULD BE PART OF
THE WORLD CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
GLOBAL PROBLEM- CAL AND TWELVE
CERTAINLY WE DO NEED TO SORT
OUT THESE OTHER ISSUES AS A
COUNTRY THE UNITED STATES WITH
THE- GOVERNMENT OF- OF- OF.
MAIENSCHEIN THAT- IT THE
CERTAINLY WE ALSO NEED TO ALSO
COOPERATE AS WELL TO TAKE TO
ADDRESS THESE EXISTENTIAL
THREATS SO. I APPRECIATE THAT-
USE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA-
WITHOUT STATE FUNDING BUT IS
GOING TO ACTUALLY LEAST WORK
WITH- ACADEMICS IS WELL OVER
AND- IN CHINA OVER IT WITH
THEIR LEADING UNIVERSITY AS
WELL TO TRY AT LEAST DEVELOP.
SOLUTIONS THAT CAN THAT TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS EXISTENTIAL
THREATS SO. THAT APPRECIATE YOU
PRESENTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN CENTER
TOWBOAT. GOOD MORNING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHILD I HAVE A QUESTION-
WITH THE HISTORY OF THE THIS
COLLABORATION HOW- HOW
RECEPTIVE AND EFFECTIVE HOW
RECEPTIVE HAS. THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT BEEN TO THE FINDINGS
OF THIS COLLABORATION IN THE
PAST. WHAT THEY'VE BEEN WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR TEAM IN FACT I
KNOW THAT THE LAST YEAR- THERE
WAS THE TRAINING SYMPOSIUM THAT
TOOK PLACE. BETWEEN THE TWO
AND- THERE HAVE BEEN ALSO TWO
DIFFERENT SEPARATE DIALOGUES
OUT THAT TOOK PLACE NOW THERE'S
ALSO I UNDERSTAND- THE STUDY
BEING DONE ON A NET- ON- CARBON
NEUTRALITY- AND THAT'S BEING
WORKED ON SO IT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN WORKING WELL LOOK BETWEEN
THE TWO IN FACT WHEN WE
INTRODUCED A BILL ORIGINALLY IT
WAS LIKE A YEAR AND A HALF AGO-
BUT BECAUSE OF A PANDEMIC WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO PURSUE. WITH
THE BILL BECAUSE IT BECOMES
HOUSING COMMITTEE SO YOU KNOW
IT HAS BEEN WORKING- WELL END
UP YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR WANTS
TO KIND OF ADD ANY MORE TO IT I
THINK THAT'S YEAH I WOULD LIKE
TO CHANGE IT LOOK- WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST THE CITY CALIFORNIA'S
ACTUALLY BEEN IN CHINA HAS
WORKED ON BUILDING
EFFICIENCIES. AND WORKING ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF CARBON
PRICING- AND THAT'S BEEN
POSITIVE NOW ARE YOU ASKING ME
IF I SEEM BIG- RESPONSES THE
VINCE WAS NO I HAVE IT IN WE
MOVED CHINA IS NOT DOING
ANYWHERE NEAR ENOUGH NORRIS
CALIFORNIA. THE UNITED STATES
DOES THE WORLD LOOK WE'RE
CHIPPING AWAY NO GUARANTEE THAT
WE DO IS SIX FEET AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT WILL WORK WITH
CHINA JOINT IS RUN BY THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA THAT'S
THE WAY IT IS BUT WE'VE GOT TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS. CALIFORNIA IS
LITERALLY FACING- REAL DANGER
AND FOREST FIRES I'M SITTING
HERE WONDERING WHETHER ALL YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO STAY HERE FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS BECAUSE
THE THREAT OF FIRE THE- OAK
TREES USED TO BE GREEN AND I
GREEN RIGHT NOW- THE- CHAPARRAL
IS TURNING BROWN AND DYING
WE'RE IN SERIOUS TROUBLE AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIRST
ADAPTED ACT AND WE'RE GOING TO
REDUCE THE GROWING. THAT THE
CONTINUING BUT THE GROWING
THREAT. AND THEN FACE THE
CHOICE THE RUSSIA AND THE U. S.
EUROPE AND EVERYBODY ELSE SO
YEAH YOU READY TO DO GOOD. HOW
MUCH- IT. WHAT I'M DOING THE I
CAN BY THE TO SOME GOOD.
SCIENTISTS CAN NOW WITH OUR.
HELPING BUT- IN COMING BACK IN
THE AT THIS THE YEAR TWO. IS HE
PRETTY. WHAT WE'RE DOING- THIS
IS FREE- YOU DOING MY WILL.
SERVICE CENTER. AND QUITE
TRYING I WOULD APPRECIATE IT IF
WE GOT A COUPLE. VOTES BECAUSE
THE POLITICAL ACTION THROUGH
THE OF OUR COUNTRY IS GOING TO
UNDERMINE THIS EVEN MORE THAN
CHINA SO I APPEAL. TO YOUR
SENSE OF- OF COMMITMENT- TO OUR
DEMOCRACY TO OUR COUNTRY
WORKING ON SOMETHING THAT- IS
NOT PERFECT- BUT I CAN TELL
YOU. BASED ON MY LONG
EXPERIENCE OF FIFTY IN A ROW
POLITICS THIS IS A POSITIVE-
HALFWAY THERE WERE FALLING AND
IT WILL BE EASY OTHER THAN
THAT- AS LONG AS I'M. CHAIRMAN
OF THE INSTITUTE. THANK YOU
GOVERNOR CENTRAL TO. THE HAVE
ANYTHING. GREAT THANK YOU VERY.
BOB YES CENTER DOLLY AND THEN
CENTER CORTESE. GOSH DARN THIS
IS WENT FULL CIRCLE NOW- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL THIS.
THE CONVERSATION IS REALLY
DRAFTED INTO. A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS SO- BUT I WANT TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT THAT IN IN MY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THE
GOVERNOR BROUGHT UP A REALLY
GOOD POINT ABOUT YOU KNOW FIRE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT-
THIS NOT IN THIS COMMITTEE MUCH
BUT- YOU CALIFORNIA'S LED THE
WAY. WHEN IT COMES TO. LEADING
THE WORLD IN. THE BILL YOU TO
BE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE PROACTIVE IN
FIGHTING OFF CARBON EMISSIONS.
I WOULD SAY WE'VE DONE WE'VE
SPENT THAT MONEY WE'VE TAX THE
PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESSES OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE RUN A LOT
OF THEM OUT AND MANY OF THOSE
COMPANIES AND CORPORATIONS
HAVE. GONE TO CHINA WHERE IT'S
A LOT EASIER- TO MANUFACTURE
AND PRODUCE THE PRODUCTS THAT
WE ALL USE- IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY DON'T. DO THE SAME
THINGS WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SO IT'S PUT CALIFORNIA AT A
MAJOR DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO BEING ABLE TO. PRODUCE
THE THINGS THAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED HERE AND PROMOTE THE JOBS
HERE- AND THEN THE SECOND THING
IS THAT WE FOCUS ON THINGS THAT
ARE- NOT ALWAYS THE BEST
PRIORITY OF THE WAY WE SPEND
THE MONEY WE HAVE. I KNOW
SOMETHING THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN. IT'S NOT JUST GOVERNOR
BUT GOVERNOR BROWN HAS BEEN
VERY ADAMANT ABOUT IT IS THE
BULLET TRAIN AND- AND THAT IS
IT IS IN MY OPINION HAS BEEN.
THE WORK THE BEST CASE OF THE
WORST AMOUNT OF MONEY I EVER
SPENT ON TRYING TO REDUCE
CARBON- AND I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'LL EVER BE COMPLETED IN. AND
ANYWAY I THINK THAT'S THE OF
SODOMY FOLKS ON AND TAKE THOSE
RESOURCES AND SPEND THEM ON
AREAS WHERE WE KNOW. WE CAN
REALLY REDUCE CARBON WHICH IS.
FORCED BUYERS. AND SO I THINK
THIS DISCUSSION HAS GONE IN THE
DIRECTION OF NOT REALLY CLOSE
TO WHAT THE BILL. FOR THE GOAL
OF THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS
TO DO AND SO FOR THOSE REASON
I'M NOT GONNA BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
GOOD POLICY DISCUSSION HERE-
THAT. IS NOT IN THIS COMMITTEES
EVEN RAIL AND SO MAYBE WE
SHOULD HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND- MAYBE WE CAN GET THE
GOVERNOR- GOVERNOR BROWN TO
COME AND DEBATE SOME OF THOSE.
OPTIONS THAT WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO. ON OUR
RELATIONSHIP. WITH CHINA. IN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH. THE HUMANS
THAT ARE PROVIDING THE THINGS
WE USE OVER THERE AND THAT
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE AND THE
BASICALLY SLAVES LET'S FACE IT
MOST. POPULAR SAY WHAT IT
REALLY IS. AND WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THE HUMAN. SIDE
OF THIS THING AND NOT SO MUCH-
THE DIFFERENCES IN. HOW WE- GET
THE PRODUCTS WE NEED AND THE
COST THE COST OF. WHAT HAPPENS
IN OTHER COUNTRIES AND THEY'RE
NOT THEY'RE NOT OUR FRIENDS AT
THE END F THE DAY THEY'RE
TAKING OUR JOBS. AND OUR
POLLUTING OUR AIR THE SAME TIME
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT MUCH
MOVEMENT AT ALL. IN THEM AND
HAVING THE ABILITY. TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE RIGHT THING TO CURB.
YOU KNOW THEIR MISSIONS. THANK
YOU. DOLLARS CENTER CORTESE. IT
IS THE GOVERNOR BROWN I'M GONNA
GO TO CENTER CORTESE. I WANTED.
OFFER RESPONSE TO MY SENATOR
THERE. BUT ALL RIGHT WE'LL GIVE
YOU A LITTLE WE'RE GIVING YOU A
LITTLE DIFFERENCE BECAUSE YOU
ARE FORMER GOVERNOR WE WOULDN'T
NORMALLY ALLOW THAT LET'S GO TO
CENTER CORTESE FIRST. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND I'LL BE BRIEF
IT'S ONE OF. THANK OF THE OFFER
PERSONALLY- SHIP- I THINK THIS
IS IMPORTANT. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T LOSE SIGHT THAT
THIS IS A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. PROGRAM AT THE
HEARTIT'S WHY IT'S HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE. I THINK- IT
WOULD BE SCARY IF WE WERE TO
GET IN THE WAY OF. OF OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM HAVING
DIALOGUE- ON AN INTERNATIONAL
BASIS REGARDLESS OF. OF
POLITICAL PARTISANSHIP OR OR
OTHER ISSUES. OF ON AN ISSUE
LIKE THIS. WE ARE COULD HAVE
ANY. DIALOGUE ON THE DEAD PLAN.
IN IN ORDER PEOPLE AND THIS- ON
THE POLITICAL SIDE TODAY THIS
IS A HUMANITARIAN ISSUE YOU
KNOW ULTIMATELY THE PLANET'S
GONNA SURVIVE. BUT THE QUESTION
IS WHETHER HUMANITY'S GONNA
SURVIVE. AND I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE A LOT OF TIME FOR
POLARIZATION AND I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT. EXAMPLE OF MOVING
FOR THE KIND OF DIALOGUE THAT.
WE SHOULD ALL BE ENGAGED IN AS
QUICKLY AS WE POSSIBLY CAN- TO
ADDRESS OF THE CLIMATE ISSUE SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING AFFORD
THEN I'M I'M PROBABLY HAPPY TO
CAST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
COMING THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO YOU FOR YOUR CLOTHES
WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED TO
GOVERNOR BROWN HELPING YOU WITH
YOUR CLOTHES NO NO NOT AT ALL
PLEASE CLICK. GOVERNOR YOU GOT
ONE MINUTE OKAY LET METELL YOU
THE FACTS ALL YOU FOLKS KNOW
ABOUT RAISING MONEY. I RAISE
TWO MILLION BUCKS FOR THIS
THING I WOULD RAISE MILLIONS
MORE WHERE DOES THAT MONEY GO
IT GOES TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HIRING PEOPLE
WE HAVE THREE PHD. WE HAVE.
STUDENTS THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE
GETTING INSTRUCTION AND
BENEFITS EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS
BECAUSE OF THIS- INSTITUTE
BECAUSE THE MONEY WILL RAISING.
NOT FROM- THE STATE SO WHAT
CENTER DOLLY HOPE YOU VOTE FOR
YOUR STUDENTS AND FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENCY AND THEN JUST
BEGIN AS A MEMBER. OF THIS-
TELL ME OF COLUSA- THE HERE ARE
SUFFERING AND THEY'RE GONNA
SUFFER MY- IN THE FIGHT. AND
THE LACK OF WATER WE'VE GOT TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THIS IS A VERY TINY
MODEST EFFORT BUT IT'S ALL GOOD
AND THERE'S NOT A SINGLE THING
WRONG WITH IT. AND ARE YOU URGE
YOU TO AT LEAST UP STAYING AND
THINK ABOUT IT A LITTLE LONGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOVERNOR-
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. CENTER
GLAZER I COULD MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT IN MY MAKING THE MOTION
THAT YES THIS BILL. ONLY IT
JUST AUTHORIZES THE REGENTS OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
ESTABLISH IT THAT'S ALL THAT
THIS BILL DOES. SO FOR THERE'S
A LOT OF SOURCE WORLD POLITICS
IN OUR WORLD SOME OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED TODAY- AND I
JUST WOULD NOTE THAT- YOU KNOW
FOR THE IF. FOR THOSE WHO CARE
ABOUT CLIMATE. THAT THIS IS A
VERY MODEST AT THE SHOW THAT
RECORD THE RECOGNIZE THAT AND I
WOULD MOVE THAT BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER AND I
THINK CENTER DOLLY HAD A FINAL
COMMENT AS WELL I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY. TO GOVERNOR BROWN
I MISS YOU. I MISS THE ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO. COMMUNICATE WITH
YOU WE HAVE NOT HAD THAT WHAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
REPUBLICANS AS MUCH. AND- IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE. THANK
YOU CENTER THE- IN Q. AS MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. BRIEFLY
AUTHORIZE THANK YOU SIR. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZERS. MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. THIRTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THAT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY SENATOR LEYVA. HI IF I
OCHO A BUG. COURTESY HI TO THE
IDEA. GO DOWN NOW GLAZER HI
PLEASE AYE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE AYE
PAN BY. CAN I. THANK YOU MADAM
CONSULT THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU SOME MEMBER ALL RIGHT WE
ARE NOW GOING TO AB TWO FIFTY
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR IT- I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WIPE DOWN
THE PODIUM FIRST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WHILE WAITING FOR THAT
A MADAM CONSULTANT LET'S OPEN
THE CALENDAR ON CONSENT PLEASE
CONSENT TO VOTING ON A VICE
CHAIR VOTING ON A SENATE-TV
DELI. DELI I CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN APPROVED. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI. THANK YOU A
MEMBERS AND- MADAM CHAIR. HE
AND THE SENATORS SO I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT THE- ASSEMBLY BL TWO
FIFTY ONE. SB TWO FIFTY ONE OR
THE BRING NECESSARY COULD HAVE
CLARIFICATION TO THE COLLEGE
ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION PROCESS
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND THE
HELP PROTECT THAT THIS PROCESS
SO AGAINST OF FRAUD AND ABUSE.
SURE WHERE AWARE. ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO HOW HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS SO WERE SHAKEN BY
THE LARGEST A COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS OF SCANDALS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES SO.
WHAT BECAME KNOWN AS OPERATION
VARSITY BLUES SO INVOLVED
THOUGH SEVERAL REPEAT YOURSELF-
INVESTIGATION BY THE FBI AND
THE ARRESTS OVER OR OVER FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS ARE INVOLVED IN
RECCA TEARING BRIBERY AND ALL
WHILE YOU'RE FRAUD IN ORDER TO
SECURE ADMISSIONS- INTENDED TO
CONVERT CITIES SO FOR THE-
CHILDREN. FORTY THE-
LEGISLATURE ROLES TO THE
LOCATION IN ACTING AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WHICH AMONG OTHER
THINGS- BROUGHT UP IMPORTANT.
ALMOST ALMOST SIDE TO THE
ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION PROCESS
WHICH ALLOWS. THE UC TO ENROLL
UP TO A 6% OF IT AS SUCH
APPLICANTS SO- WHO DO NOT
COMMITTEE UC ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS BUT OTHERWISE-
TEMAS TREES. HIGH POTENTIAL FOR
SUCCESS. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE KINDS OF- ABUSE SO
WE SAW IT IN THE OPERATION
VARSITY BLUE SCANDAL A. B. AT
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE REQUIRED
DO SO ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION
SKIP HOP CANDIDATES TO THE CUT
TO BE REVIEWED BY A PANEL OF
THREE YOU SEE. CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATORS HOWEVER IT DID
NOT DEFINE WHO THIRTY OUT
CAMPUS COOL WHAT COULD NOT THE
PARTICIPATING IN THE ADMISSION
BY. EXCEPTION PROCESS. PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY OHIO THAT'S-
COMMITTEE ON ALICE SO POINTS ON
THE- SINCE THE DEVELOPMENT.
OFFICE IS ARE NOT OF THE AT THE
NOT CHARGE WITH YEAR CAMP A
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT AND THE
FUND RAISING IT TO YOU SEE WHAT
THE CSU AB TWO FIFTY ONE
REMOVES A ANY DOLLAR OF OUR OWN
DO OR IMPROPER INFLUENCE
SOMEONE BUT MISSION DECISIONS
BY PROHIBITING STAFF. WILL
ASSOCIATE IT WITH T. EXTERNAL
WITH. RELATION ACTIVITIES SO
FROM. ON ADMISSION DECISIONS SO
FOR INCOMING STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE MALL
SIX EXCEPTIONAL HIGH YOUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE WORLD
IT IS SUCH ROGER THE JOB WORLD
AND A CENTRAL TO OUR SUCCESS SO
ONE OF THE STRONGEST IT
ECONOMICS ART AND THE VIBRANT
DIVERS OUR POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY. ON A PERSONAL NOTE
HAVING RECEIVED A QUALITY
EDUCATION AND EVENTUALLY UP MY
PHD. I PERSONALLY IN NORMAL. I
WOULD NOT BE US STANDING HERE
BEFORE YOU AS A MEMBER IF IT
WILL NOT THOUGH FOR MY
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES SO.
WE MUST- TAKE KERR EVERY STEP
ON TO PRESERVE THIS SUCH CATION
OPPORTUNITIES AWFUL ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND THE PROTECT
AGAINST- THE TYPE OF ABUSE AND
THE FRAUD TO ACT UP WAS SO
REVEALED. TO US JUST A TWO YEAR
CYCLE. AB TWO FIFTY ONE BILLS
UPON IMPORTER TO SAP'S TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ADMISSION BY
EXCEPTION PROCESS AND ENSURE
FAIR BACK DOUBLE ACCESO TO
EQUALITY HIGHER EDUCATION FULL
OR DISSOLVING CALIFORNIA'S.
THIS BILL PASSED A UNANIMOUSLY-
OUT OVER ASSEMBLY HYATT
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND A WITH
A NORMAL NO VOTES ON ASSEMBLY
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTIVELY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL ONE EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO SUPPORT
WE HAVE NO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE WILL GO TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE TO HAVE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIFTY ONE. SEEING NO ONE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE CALLING IN WISHING TO
SUPPORT AB. TWO FIFTY ONE.
MISTER MODERATE ARE YOU THERE I
WOULD LIKE TO PICK UP PERFECT
AND THANK YOU SORRY I WAS
BEATEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AB. TWO FIFTY ONE.
HI AND AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A B. TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SIR WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FIFTY ONE.
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
MISTER MODERATOR BACKED YOU DO
WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB TWO
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A B. TWO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND LINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CLOSE .COM
POTTER COUNTY THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN TO SHOW UP WITH PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR THERE'S
NO OTHER PRTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DO WE HAVE ANYONE WITH ANY
COMMENTS CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS
CENTRO CHOI BOGUE. I JUST THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND- WINDY ADAM.
OPPORTUNITY ARISES TO BE HAPPY
TO MOVE. THE BILL FORWARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SIR. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR OCHO
VOGUE MAN CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE NUMBER TWO
A. B. TWO FIFTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SENATOR LEYVA HI. IF
I OCHO ABODE HI THE CHILL
BOGUCKI COURTESY. COURTESY I
DELI. DELI I GLAZER. GLAZER
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI AN
HIGH BILLS OUT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVE A GREAT
DAY THANK YOU MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE OUR LAST BILL THE DAY
WHICH IS GOING TO BE PRESENTED
BY SENATOR GLAZERS GLAZER WHICH
I COULD DO IT FROM YOUR SEAT
VERY GOOD PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SCA FIVE- CURRENTLY. TO
STUDENTS SERVE ON THE UC BOARD
OF REGENTS HOWEVER ONLY ONE HAS
VOTING POWER- THIS BILL IF
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA WILL INCREASE THE
VOTING RIGHTS OF THE STUDENT
MEMBERS. OF THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS BY ALLOWING THE
EXISTING NON VOTING STUDENT
REGION. TO RECEIVE VOTING POWER
GIVEN BOTH STUDENTS VOTING
RIGHTS- AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KNOW WHEN A STUDENTS
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD. THEY
SERVE A YEAR AS A NON VOTING
MEMBER OF THE BOARD AND AT THE
COMPLETION OF THAT YEAR THEN
THEY BECOME THE VOTING STUDENT
REGION. THIS BILL WOULD INVEST
BOTH STUDENTS WITH A VOTE- DOES
THAT STUDENT REGION WOULD BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AS A VOTING
MEMBER FROM THE START- AS WE
ALL KNOW THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS PLACE TO DRAMATIC
BURDEN ON THE UNIVERSITIES TEN
CAMPUS SYSTEM. AND IT'S FORCING
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO MAKE HARDER AND
HARDER DECISIONS ABOUT. THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT STUDENTS
ARE THE ONES WHO KNOW MOST
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY
ARE FACING. AND THEIR VOICES
WILL BE ESSENTIAL IN TACKLING
THESE CHALLENGES AND POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS. STUDENTS BRING
DIVERSE EXPERIENCES SPECIAL
PERSPECTIVES. AND THEIR
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO OFFER
THE BOARD DATED A FEEDBACK
ABOUT THEIR UNIVERSITIES. AND
HOW THEY FUNCTION IN MANY
IMPORTANT PLACES. S. C. A. FIVE
WILL ALLOW ONE ADDITIONAL
VOTING STUDENT REGENT. AS YOU
KNOW WELL THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
AT THE UC. AND A SECOND STUDENT
VOICE- IS WARRANTED TODAY HAVE.
A LEXUS YEAR AGO SAID THE
CURRENT STUDENT REGENT
DESIGNATE. AND ALEX NILES THE
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION'S
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS VICE CHAIR
TO TESTIFY THANK YOU FOR THE
BOTTOM THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR I
THINK YOUR FIRST WITNESS- THAT
YOU MENTIONED IS NOT ON THE
LINE BUT WE DO HAVE YOUR SECOND
WITNESS ON THE LINE. ALEX NILE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. HI THANK YOU SO MUCH-
I'M ALISON A SECOND YEAR
STUDENT AT UC SANTA BARBARA.
CALIFORNIANS VESTED IN ENTIRE
EDUCATION SYSTEM ON THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT EVERYONE IN
OUR STATE WOULD BE BEST OFF
WHEN EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO
REALIZE THE FULL MEASURE OF
THEIR TALENT. THE COLLEGES CSU
AND UC ALIKE SYMBOLISES OF
ALWAYS BEEN ESSENTIAL TO MAKING
GOOD ON THAT MISSION TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THE UC
STUDENT REGENT STARTED THE
BOARD'S BASIC NEEDS COMMITTEE
WHICH SPARKED DEBATE ON THE
BOARD AND IN THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS
FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO THRIVE.
THEY DON'T NEED A CONVERSATION
ON TUITION HIKES PROTECTING THE
MISSION OF OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CSU
THE LEGISLATURE RT FROM THE
NEED FIRST YEAR REPRESENTATION
BY CODIFYING VOTING MEMBERSHIP
FOR TWO STUDENT TRUSTEES AT
EACH. IT'S TIME TO DO THE SAME
AT THE UC BY PASSING AS SHE DID
FIVE. BECAUSE THE BOARD OF
REGENTS ALWAYS DOES TO
COMMITTEE BRIT COMMITTEE BREAK
OUT SIMULTANEOUSLY STUDENTS
ONLY HAVE A VOTING
REPRESENTATION ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD COMMITTEES AT THIS TIME.
WHEN THE UC WORSE FOR STUDENTS
IT WORKS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
BUT PASSING AS SHE FIVE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BRING US A STEP
CLOSER TO GUARANTEEING FULL
ADEQUATE YOU REPRESENTATION ON
THE BOARD OF REGENTS. AND
THEREBY IMPROVE HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR ENTIRE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND LET US KNOW IF ALEXIS CALLS
IN BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE SHE IS
ON THE LINE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE FOUR
SUPPORT. SCREEN NONE LET'S GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING
NONE MISTER MODERATOR GOING TO
COME BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO'S CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE. TO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE FILED BY ZERO. MADAM CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP THANK YOU
SIR WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WE WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE DECEIVER OF ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE GOING
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. C. A. FIVE.
JUSTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. C.
A. FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. INITIAL
OPPOSITION FOR S. C. A. FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD- I'M
I'M WONDERING WHEN I CAN OPPOSE
A. B. EIGHT FIVE SIX BECAUSE
YOU DON'T SEEM TO BE PRESENTING
IT. AND YOU SAID YOU'RE ON THE
LAST BILL THIS BILL MEADOW
WHERE IS MY OPPORTUNITY TO THE
BILL ON THE AGENDA. THE BILL IS
ON CONSENT SO IT IS NOT BEING
HEARD TODAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
PLEASE GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS.
AS A FINAL. REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR SCA FIVE. AND I'M NOT I'M
SURE NOBODY IS GOING UP THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR FOR IT WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DISEASE SENATOR PAM. THANK
THANK YOU- AND CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE
STRIKES THAT DID ONE CLARIFY-
BECAUSE AN ANALYSIS IT
INDICATES THAT THE VOTING
MEMBERSHIP ACTUALLY INCREASES
BY TWO SO IS THAT. BUT YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S ONE
VOTING STUDENTS SO WE'RE TAKING
THE OTHER STUDENTS SO I'M JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT AND THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
PERHAPS YOU CAN ALSO DRESSES
THAT. HELLO STUDENTS SELECTED I
UNDERSTAND SELECTED BY THE
REGION'S THEMSELVES THIS THIS
AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY GIVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT IF PERHAPS
THE SUSAN CELLS CAN VOTE FOR
THEIR OWN REPRESENTATIVES
INSTEAD OF THE BODY ITSELF
BASICALLY POINTING SOMEONE TO
THERE'S TO THEMSELVES. PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
IN REGARD TO THE FIRST
QUESTION- THE STUDENT REGENT
THAT SELECTED TODAY IS AN
OPTIONAL. IT'S AN AUTHORIZATION
BY THE CONSTITUTION BUT IT'S AN
OPTIONAL CHOICE BY THE BY THE
BOARD. AND SO- THE BOARD MAKE
UP IS TWENTY FIVE BUT THE BOARD
HAS ALLOWED A STUDENT TO BE
DESIGNATED AS A VOTING MEMBER-
BY CHOICE THIS MEMBER THIS
MEASURE. WOULD ACTUALLY. TELL
THAT DESIGNATE TO VOTING
STUDENTS- AS A CONSTITUTIONAL
CHANGE AND THAT'S WHY THE
MEMBERSHIP INCREASES TO TWENTY
SEVEN. TO TWENTY FIVE- IN
REGARD TO THE SELECTION AND
STUDENT AND LIKE TO ASK. OF MY
WITNESSES SAID THEY COULD
ADDRESS THAT THAT THAT PROCESS
IF IT IF IT WOULD YES A
CHALLENGE FOR YOU STILL ON THE
LINE. AND JUST JUST TO CLARIFY
I'M JUST SAYING THAT IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE ACE S. C. A.
DOES IT ACTUALLY SPEAK TO THE
SELECTION OR DOES IT SILENCE ON
SELECTION PROCESS SO. IT'S
PRETTY CHEAP THE TESTIMONY
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE DOING IT. NOW
BUT DOES IT CONSTRAINED-
SELECTION. ORDERS BECAUSE WE'RE
MAKING COSTUMES AENDMENT IS
YOUR IS A PERMISSIVE EOUGH TO
ALLOW ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF
SELECTION THAT PERHAPS COULD
BETTER REFLECT THE STUDENT
VOICE STAND. THAT REGION SOME
CELLS ESSENTIALLY POINTING THE
STUDENT A DAYLIGHT. TO THEIR
OWN BODY TO VOTE. ALL OF THE
AUTHOR ANSWER BUT I BELIEVE
IT'S OPTIONAL. I'M SCOTT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WHAT COMMITTED
TO THE ISSUE THAT YOU RAISED-
AND AS FAR AS I KNOW IT'S NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN THAN HAPPY
TO- AT WELCOME ANY SUGGESTIONS
OR THOUGHTS ABOUT IT AND- WOULD
ENCOURAGED BY THE STUDENT
LEADERSHIP TO ALSO WEIGH IN ON
THAT. BUT I THINK YOU RAISE AN
IMPORTANT POINT AND I'M I'M-
VERY INTERESTED IN. TRYING TO
WORK THAT ISSUE AN APPROPRIATE
WAY. OKAY I WOULD JUST SAY IS
THAT IT'S AS YOU'RE IN SOME
INDIA CA. OF COURSE CUT TO TWO
MEN THAT WOULD CONSTRAIN AND
SAY THAT THE ONLY WAY TO SELECT
THE STUDENT IS THE- REGION'S
THEMSELVES OF POINTING AT. IT
SILENT IN THE- IF THE
OPPORTUNITY WHICH WE MAY
ADDRESS WHETHER IT'S AND
LEGISLATION OR OTHER.
MECHANISMS TO ADDRESS THAT ARE
YOU SEE ITSELF AND ADDRESS
THAT. THAT'S FINE- I JUST WANNA
BE SURE THAT THERE WASN'T
LANGUAGE INDIA C. ITSELF.
PERTAINING TO STUDENT REGENT
THAT WOULD MANDATE THAT THE-
REGENTS THEMSELVES ARE THE
APPOINTING BODY FOR THE
STUDENTS REASONS. AS I READ IT
IS SILENT SO I THINK YOU I
THINK YOUR CONCERNS- ARE FINE.
ANY OTHER. SKEWS ME. YES AND-
TROUBLED. SO MUCH A QUESTION
BUT MORE OF A COMMENT- SENATE
WHICH IS WHY OF THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS MOTION AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IT JUST MAKES
ABSOLUTE SENSE I I'M SURE THAT
WHEN. THE SYSTEM WAS ORIGINALLY
IMPLEMENTED THE BODY COUNT WAS
IT AS AS LARGE AS WE HAVE NOW
SO WE HAVE MORE STUDENTS THAT
ARE BEING REPRESENTATIVE AND
HAVING ADDITIONAL VOTING
MEMBERS ON THERE JUST MAKES
LOGICAL SENSE SO THANK YOU.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU SENATOR TROUBLED
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER MCGUIRE CENTER
GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK A MEMBERS FOR THEIR
QUESTIONS AND SUPPORT I KNOW
THAT THE STUDENTS AT UC
RIVERSIDE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF.
OF HAVING THAT SECOND STUDENT
VOICE AND- TEAM MEMBER WOULD BE
INTERESTED IF THIS BILL WAS
FORWARDED JOINING AS A CO
AUTHOR WE WOULD WELCOME THAT
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE
NUMBER ELEVEN S. C. A. FIVE THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS SENATOR LEYVA FINE
LEYVA AYE OCHO ABOVE. A
TROUBLED AYE COURTESY AYE
COURTESY AYE. DALY DALY NOT
VOTING GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN FIGHT
AND I THAT BILLS OUT ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE DAY
THANK YOU ALSO TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US. WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU EVERYONE ALSO FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.